فاير جروس هي المدير العام لوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه قلق بشان عدم تحقيق تقدم في
المحادثات مع ايران
لم نحصل حتى الان على اي شيء منهم عليهم
التعاون معنا يجب ان تقدم ايران الاجوبه
اللازمه على الاسئله التي طرحناها عليها
ثلاث مواقع غير مولانا فضلا عن تقديم
تفسير حول اثار اليورانيوم المخصب لكن
وصلت ايران تخصيبه الى مستويات اعلى بكثير
من الحد الاقصى الذي ينص عليه اتفاقه 2015
اتفاق تحاول دول الغرب عن طريق محادثات
غير مباشره لكن بسبب الاحتجاجات التي
يواجهها النظام حاليا اصبح الامل باحياء
الاتفاق النوويلا من جهتها اعلى المانيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يسعى الى تبني عقوبات
جديده ضد طهران بسبب حمله القمع الدموي
وكان هذا هو اردرا ان تقويض علاقات قديمه
له تداعيات طويله المدى يمكن لالمانيا ان
تختار المشاركه لمواجهه التحديات المشتركه
او المواجهه وسيكون ردنا متناسبا وحزما من
المقرر ان يعقد وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي اجتماعا في بروكسل الاثنين
المقبل للعمل على حزمه جديده من العقوبات